[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'éducation nationale et de la jeunesse
monsieur le ministre il est de notre
devoir en tant que société de veiller à
la protection au bien-être de nos
enfants ils sont les piliers de notre
avenir votre ministère et ses agents
jouent chaque jour un rôle majeur pour
leur pour les enfants et leur devenir
mais une telle politique est forcément
interministérielle tant elle nécessite
la mobilisation de tous les ministères
l'éducation nationale les ministères
sociaux la santé l'intérieur la justice
bien évidemment mais également le sport
la culture l'emploi l'économie
l'enseignement supérieur il faut toute
une société pour élever un enfant hier à
l'occasion du comité interministériel à
l'enfance que vous avez fait autour de
Charlotte cobel ministre de l'enfance et
de ellisabeth be première ministre vous
avez participé à la présentation de la
réponse du gouvernement en faveur des
enfants je ne peux que saluer puisque je
le porte depuis de longs mois votre
volonté d'action en faveur du d'une
véritable éducation au corps à la
sexualité et à la bienveillance parmi
les réponses que vous avez apporté il y
a nécessairement la place de l'école qui
dans vos annonces effectu une véritable
révolution celle du soutien à la
réussite et à l'ambition scolaire des
enfants protégés quand ces enfants sont
protégés accueillis car en difficulté
familiale ou victime de violence l'école
doit devenir une bouée à laquelle ils
doivent se raccrocher or ce que l'on
voit c'est que 61 % des adolescents de
15 ans placés en établissement sont
toujours dans un niveau relevant du
premier cycle voire un niveau
élémentaire que seulement 20 %
obtiennent un baccalauréat général sans
parler de tous ceux qui quittent le
système sans diplôme avec de fait une
promesse de difficile insertion alors
Monsieur le Ministre pourriez-vous nous
détailler ce que contient le nouveau
dispositifs scolarité protégée que vous
avez annoncé hier pour que enfin demain
notre République soit la chance des
enfants protégés